few years ago my son who was an  electrical engineer was interning at  tesla dad why don't you own some tesla i  worked there as an intern and i said i  want to short that stock it's such a  joke it's a car company trading at a  ridiculous price he said  no you're the joke you don't understand  what tesla does i work there  it's not a car company it's a data  company every mile a tesla drives it  goes into the database of mapping for  autonomous cars  i thought  [ __ ] i didn't know that he said no  kidding you have a ton of money why  don't you buy some of this stock so just  before i went on the air i took my phone  out and i bought a whack of the stock in  my personal account and i forgot about  it  one day i opened up the thing  and i was up like a thousand percent